واوكرانيا لا تستهدف اي سفن مدنيه او اي
موانئ مدنيه حتى لو كانت تحت الاحتلال
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم روسيا تقول انها احبطتها
هجمات اوكرانيه على ميناء في البحر الاسود
واوكرانيا تؤكد ان اضرار كبيره لحقت
بسفينه انزال روسيه في البحر الاسود
والمتحدث باسم بحريتها يؤكد للجزيره انه
لا علاقه لكيف بتلك الاضرار في الاثناء
اصدر بوتين قرارا يفرض التجنيد الالزاميه
على المواطنين بين سن 18 عاما وثلاثين
عاما
في النيجر قاده الانقلاب يعلقون اتفاقيات
تعاون مع فرنسا ويهددون بالرد على اي
عدوان وفرنسا تقول ان السلطات الشرعيه فقط
مخوله بالغاء الاتفاقيات وبازوم يحذر في
مقاله في الواشنطنبوزت ام النفوذ روسيا في
منطقه الساحل عبر فاجنر في حين قالت موسكو
ان التدخل الاجنبيه لن يحل الازمه
مؤشر الاسعار العالميه لمنظمه الفاو يرتفع
في يوليو الماضي من ادنى مستوياته في
عامين مع صعود اسواق الزيوت النباتيه الذي
قفز 12% مقارنه بشهر يونيو عقب تجدد
التوترات بشان الصادرات الحبوب من
اوكرانيا والمخاوف بشان الانتاج العالمي
ابل تعلنه مبيعات وارباحا تفوق توقعات بول
ستريت لتسجل واحدا وثمانين مليارا و800
مليون دولار على الرغم من تراجع المبيعات
هواتف ايفون الذي عوضه مبيعات قويه
للخدمات التي بلغت ايراداتها 21 مليارا
ومئتين مليون دولار الى